all right you ready to have fun fun
begins now ready when when does it start
hi I'm Greg hi I'm Sandra amber and I
are going to watch the trailer today for
American God American God was requested
by many one person even left a comment
recently saying why I did a hell I be
not reacted to the American Gods trailer
yet and here's a hell it is he wasn't
the first one requested it was actually
Eugene 1988 Thank You Jean 1988
you get the shadow I wonder when you
were born American God
here we go what - God they really
believe in who you you wouldn't believe
me if I told you the dude my man shut up
moon he just looked in a lot of world
amazing in it he's gotten yourself mixed
up in some really weird [ __ ]
whoa cigar anyway I'm doing good science
so you trying to start a war already and
will
who got here hi we are changing we need
you Fivefinger Chozen cuz we know this
feels really they would like a drink
when I can pretend things are never
going back
Oh such interesting please like ya think
what's that about is it it is it a
restaurant they all work it out really
God side that looks really cool to me
yeah I mean it's my kind of show words
you know it looks gritty and violin I
love those kind of shows honestly how do
they feel like you watch too many of
those
I like the grit you don't know my last
trick you you don't know about life you
know
well these guys come from like a lot of
HBO shows and like violent shows like
these trainers have worked on my
cannibal and here I have a Hannibal yeah
and the other guy like one of the other
guy that he also co-wrote Logan and
alien covenant and like other shows as
well like they've worked on like
Deadwood HBO these creators have worked
on a lot of great television for Heroes
which is some of my favorite absolutely
absolutely at here I mean you got ian
mcshane who I think is immediately
perfectly capped because just as genre
in the world a machine has the right
presence and voice he's kind of like a
darker version of like like his
portrayal the things kind of reminds me
of like on the darker side of a like
Morgan Freeman is kind of seen like like
in John wick he's like oh no baby I know
everything but I'm still mysterious
about it
and here he is like yes it's modern day
and I heard American Gods I was like
it's gonna be like a gangster show or
something and then double you know it
actually is about like God
you know is it uh questions I didn't get
this on the trailer is it is it based on
the old Egyptian gods I don't know um or
linear because I have so much historical
knowledge on Egypt and it's gone so I
should know answer that for you I was
like looking for like oh is this you
know is it based off of like the Greek
gods or the Egyptian gods or anything
versus just all made-up characters it
would be interesting if it was based off
of yeah Great God because there's a lot
to chew on from Egyptian it would be the
mummy and it does very clearly say
American God so maybe they are trying to
invent their own yeah oh this is all
just Jesus and Satan and you know this
all the things all just like a guy's is
like joining a letter dating yeah happen
it is activated with the way it's all
looks really cool I mean there's a
character it has that kind of like nasty
dark element to it which I do like
seeing in TV it looks like high-octane
and drama I much I don't really know the
characters just in 1 minute and 22
second trailer out of like a multiple
episodes show this looks like my kind of
TV really I don't like that I didn't get
to know any of the characters very well
from the trailer but it is this the
trailer but the plots intriguing you
know a little bit yeah I really like
that they actually have they seem to
actually have godlike powers yeah
exactly and it is an ensemble film which
means like if one character storyline
just will played out you can probably
meet like a demigod yeah on the line
gets a lot of longevity to the series
yeah and it also a diverse cast
yes diverse immigrant is always a plus
yes and I think it's important when you
have like superheroes or gods it just
makes it so much better if they actually
look different
yeah I'll don't just look like a white
Clark Kent or something well there's
something to be said that they looked at
that big pop it up until this point for
a reason right this is going it so well
about my American gosh
I think we're gonna do it they putting
American entitles is a great thing you
know American Horror Story American
crime story that's train wreck and god
yeah but I do like it it's an ensemble
cast and I I'm kind of sad that it's on
stores because I don't have stars a lot
of people do but stars do continue to
evil they do - vs. Evil Dead and that's
an awesome fun violent thrill ride of a
show this looks to be you know so just
being fun looks like there's going to be
some pretty serious actors in this thing
I feel like all the shots feel very
expression it to like the visual style
is more than just go they got cool
vision there everything seems like very
specifically framed it's more than just
gritty because we saw that shot of like
it's almost beautiful thing to blood
yeah right
yeah there's an island like it's cool to
look at yeah look at it's really violent
but it's really cool look at ya selling
a painting a lot of this and I like the
big way to tell almost the end to bring
out the little girl zombie because we
both warning sighs yeah you know the
trailer escalated well yeah so our top a
little subdued and you see that as the
show is going to keep going it's going
to get crazier and crazier
yeah oh man oh it feels like it could be
a little scary too it's like right at my
level of like being able to handle the
scary yeah they're like a horror show
but it looks like there might be some
scary elements in there for sure I'm
gonna have to wash this with a light on
okay yeah that's that's that's the level
that we're at that's my level of concern
for a second cause right now I
understand I'm gonna watch this with
softbox wise pointed at the TV as you
should
pieces I'll be bound
alright well thanks to everyone who
requested this especially Eugene 1988
congratulations your name was mentioned
in a video for a trailer that a few
people requested and since this is
coming out a little late maybe only a
few hundred watched
subscriber the real reject always
positive and blaster on the amber
plaster channel where she's all
plastering around her self all over that
thing it's along with her friend Renee
mister we have a react series right now
we're reacting to the Resident Evil
series with my co-host from s close to
me Renee Ariel
yeah yeah it's going to be really
interesting it's been well it was a
journey with Star Wars and it's going to
be a real journey with resident evil
because I didn't know anything about it
going into very different journeys this
time do my video grow up with your
community and upload that that is I not
uploaded yet but it will be by the time
this is uploaded good